face it tiger marvel comics at the
jackpot in 1966 when they introduced
Mary Jane Watson to the spider-man
Methos over the years she's evolved into
a complicated and compelling character
and arguably the greatest love of
Spidey's life and that long lasting
prominence means that she's also been
featured in almost every Spiderman
adaptation from Saturday morning
cartoons to the big screen he has every
version of Mary Jane Watson ranked from
worst to best
spider-man 67 Mary Jane's appearance in
the 1967 spider-man cartoon played by
peg Dixon isn't really bad like
everything that happened on this show
it's just sort of and explicable while
she has the name Mary Jane at this
version is more of a mashup of MJ and
Gwen Stacy and is even portrayed as
Captain George Stacy sneeze either way
it's pretty weird that one of the major
characters of the entire spider-man saga
makes her only appearance in the 52
episode run in a story about how she
gets duped into go-go dancing at a club
so that the kingpin can brainwash city
officials with a mind-control machine
the 60s spider-man unlimited after Fox's
popular spider-man animated series ended
in 1998 someone had the idea to reboot
the show in a way that fans could choose
to view as a continuation but that
avoided everything this show had already
done with that in mind they launched a
new series of the truly wild premise of
spider-man following venom carnage and
hero astronaut John Jameson - an
alternate version of earth populated
mostly by human animal hybrids
oh and instead of just his usual spider
powers Spidey had a brand new nanotech
suit with built-in robot weapons
needless to say it only lasted one
season by necessity that premise meant
leaving most of Spidey's establish
continuity behind so Mary Jane only
appears briefly in the first episode to
give Peter the helpful advice that he
should fake his death so he doesn't have
to be spider-man anymore Jennifer Hale
does a solid job with a few moments she
has but there's not much there beyond
telling spider-man that he shouldn't be
spider-man any more spectacular
spider-man the primary function of the
Mary Jane we see in the show list but
title of spider-man series voiced by
Vanessa Marshall
comes from the bit about Pizza Parker
literally shuddering in horror every
I may say she has a wonderful
personality it's an update of the joke
that accompanied the character and her
earliest comic appearances but here it
just lands flats but one thing a pizza
Parker actually seems like a huge jerk
but in itself isn't a bad thing if you
learned a lesson something that usually
requires at that uncle this time though
there's no real teachable moment Mary
Jane's arrival doesn't really teach him
to not judge people by their appearances
it's more like he learns that people
with the wonderful personalities can
also be hot not quite as solid a moral
lesson as the thing about power and
responsibility spider-man the new
animated series spider-man the new
animated series was a weird little
experiment for a lot of reasons
including a computer animated style that
definitely stood out in 2003 but never
quite worked for web slinging action for
another the cast was stocked with
celebrities in an effort to hook the
teen audience that was tuning in for
MTV's take on spider-man that's how we
got Lisa Loeb best known for the hit
single stay I missed you stepping into
the role of Mary Jane Watson she was a
solid choice bringing an entirely
different sort of character than would
ever seen before with MJ unfortunately
the janky animation just underlines of
this Mary Jane has zero chemistry with
spider-man although that probably has
less to do with MJ than with the
cartoonish big bad wolf voice that Neil
Patrick Harris puts on to disguise his
version of Spidey from Peter Parker's
friends handy piece of information that
sword thing how'd you know long story
but the point is we make a good team yes
we do the spider-man trilogy Kirsten
Dunst performance as Mary Jane in Sam
Raimi's cinematic spider-man trilogy is
a study in extremes
she's a primary love interest of the
entire saga although the third film
flirts for throwing Gwen Stacy into the
mix really though she's just there as a
prop to make Mary Jane sheath with
jealousy and that's sort of the problem
throughout the films Mary Jane's
understandable frustrations of Peter are
presented to us as a callous
misunderstanding of the burden that he
has to bear a spider-man that's not
entirely her falls as a character though
Peter deciding not to tell her his
identity at the end of the first movie
is an almost inexplicable choice given
their history to make matters even more
frustrating
she's kidnapped by supervillains in all
three movies and while that might be the
default role of a super heroes love
interest it gets
petter dev with all that said though the
Raimi trilogies MJ really does have a
lot of great moments too including the
upside down kiss that stands as one of
the most iconic superhero movie moments
of the 2000s Cepeda Mann toei's 1978
adaptation of spider-man as a Japanese
tokusatsu show didn't exactly line up
with its source material instead of a
high-school student being bitten by a
radioactive spider for instance Dirk by
racing champion Takuya Yamashiro was
granted fantastic wall-crawling powers
by a dying alien which included a
50-foot sword wielding robot named leo
pardon with that in mind it shouldn't be
surprising that sakuya's love interest
Hitomi Sakuma is pretty different from
her American counterparts
while Mary Jane was a model an actress
by the 70s it Tomy played by Rika Miura
is actually a little closer to Peter
Parker
she's an intrepid photojournalist
working for a character that bears more
than a pressing resemblance to Jay jonah
Jameson the only big differences about
Japan's JJJ is actually Amazonas a field
commander of the evil Iron Cross army
also since the Tommies actually taking
pictures of spider-man rather than just
selling off some extremely marketable
selfies it turns out she's a better
photo journalists and pizza - spider-man
94 by the time Spiderman hit the
airwaves in 1994 only two years after
the debut of Batman the Animated Series
and the x-men cartoon the standard have
been set pretty high it might not hit
the high points of BTS or the memorable
theme song of x-men instead going with a
truly bizarre techno song about spider
blood but there's an entire generation
with some fond memories of this version
of Spidey much like the rest of the show
this Mary Jane was a pretty accurate
translation of the character as seen in
the comics she was a great foil for
Peter Parker and Sarah ballantine would
find their way into a lot of Spidey
readers heads as a default voice of the
character at the same time she's not
perfect if nothing else the idea that a
fashion model will be walking around in
this outfit is even less believable than
a dude getting super-strength from a
radioactive spider bite ultimate
spider-man with roles on the Powerpuff
Girls Teen Titans go and plenty of other
animated projects Tara Strong is one of
the most prolific and prominent voice
actresses
of the 21st century the fact that she
spent four years playing Mary Jane
Watson and that a solid job offer is
hardly surprising even beyond Strong's
performance ultimate spider-man's Mary
Jane is one of the most interesting and
engaging animated takes on the character
in a lot of ways
she's matched up with Lois Lane an
aspiring reporter who's eager to land a
job at the Daily Bugle that gives her
interactions of Pizza and spider-man an
entirely different meaning and shifting
the day job on - MJ allowed this version
of spider-man to be recruited by shield
lead a team of teenage heroes and have
cross-dimensional team ups with heroes
from throughout the spider-verse
ultimate spider-man is a real hidden gem
and MJ is a huge part of what makes it
work spider-man homecoming if you want
to get technical about her zendaya
doesn't actually play Mary Jane and 2017
spider-man homecoming instead she plays
a character named Michelle whose last
name Jones and the fact that she goes by
MJ around friends or kept from
moviegoers until the movies final
moments the reason it works is that
Michelle's personality and
characterization are completely
different from what we've come to expect
for Mary Jane Watson she has a bored
sardonic attitude replacing the smiling
popularity that would all expect but
that's also what makes her the perfect
MJ I believe you guys are this lame
party you're sure - am I
mary-jane has always been about
subverting expectations her first
appearance in the comic was built on the
idea that Peter had been intentionally
ducking out on meeting her and after
Gwen Stacy's death she was finally
revealed to have a personality that went
a lot deeper than how she'd been
portrayed most importantly the reveal
that she'd known Peter secret identity
since before she actually met him
redefined the core of her character and
it's hinted at in the way Zendaya's MJ
looks at Peter at the end of the movie
homecomings version might be called
Michelle Jones but it turns out that a
Mary Jane by any other name can be every
bit as good as the others